cela fait six jours que ce cidre et
jarvis en fauteuil roulant cet
architecte spécialisé dans
l'accessibilité va vivre la vie d'un
handicapé moteur durant 21 jours
membre de l'association des paralysés de
france elle fait cela pour mieux
appréhender les difficultés
c'est pendant une heure en fait que vous
vous rendez compte vraiment de
l'inaccessibilité de notre environnement
et des modifications que ça peut
engendrer sur notre quotidien
donc souvent fait une heure de fauteuils
on se lève on dit ok d'accord
effectivement il ya des contraintes mais
ça s'arrête là direction le centre ville
elle veut observer les bonnes pratiques
et des manques en matière
d'accessibilité s'obliger à bouger lui
permet aussi de mieux appréhender des
difficultés la plus grosse difficulté
c'est pas tant physique
c'est une difficulté psychique
parce qu'en fait il ya plein de ya plein
de sites où vous pouvez pas aller il ya
plein de de commerce que vous pouvez pas
accéder et en fait je crois que
psychologiquement c'est se dire j ai pas
le droit est alors que d'habitude j'ai
le droit et c'est là en fait pousser un
peu frustrant en fait ici et là de
nombreuses marches et une petite
solution
vous avez un bouton d'appel là ils sont
fermés
vous appuyez
vous avez normalement une rente amovible
et du coup après vous pouvez accéder au
magasin avec ned rendre plus vivable le
handicap c'est une question à laquelle
l'office du tourisme de tours a déjà
réfléchi ces sites brégeat art est
invité à prendre place dans un petit
pour casser le rapport verticale
entre la conseillère et l
l'office est déjà tout un programme de
visites à lui proposé en fonction de son
handicap à travers cette expérience la
jeune femme veut trouver des mécènes
pour financer sa future association de
professionnels de l'accessibilité avec
ses quatre autres partenaires
elle veut former et sensibiliser les
entreprises locales à cette cause
et pourquoi pas à s'inviter sur le
terrain des politiques